[Music]
welcome back to all the record we're
talking about
whatever we want what's up
[Laughter]
i don't know what is up and today we got
dante we got anthony we got nick
we got steve we got me we got bar let's
go
great intro wow that's how it's done
very soft spoken intro i loved it what
is up i don't know what you've been up
to man i haven't seen in like
a month two weeks no like a month i was
in mexico i did cabo i didn't y'all been
vacationing
vacationing i mean i did a little quick
vacation five day vacation
probably that's a good vacation it was
good it was good cabo was cool we you
know
my first time on a plane since uh since
since
a weird tea or not yeah it was weird
what was weird about that everyone's far
apart outside and again i'm playing a
gentleman i was like
yeah i'm sitting next to my girl on this
side first of all i haven't had you know
but
i'm usually like the window person but
then my girl's like you ain't gonna sit
i'm sitting by the window because i
don't know who the [ __ ] that is isn't
that normal
that was weird to sit next to someone
for like a few hours that's like
on you and they're like oh this dude i
don't know you like leaning hard
against your girl like i don't know this
dude but it was fine at the end of dad's
fall asleep i'm just like
if i catch it i catch it yeah at this
point right right
you're in a tube in the air with like 70
people but once we got to mexico it was
dope we had we had a house when
i didn't see many people went to dinner
one night and had the mask on
but you know it's like everyone should
start coming to speak to you in spanish
and you're like
they're a mexican they thought i guess a
thousand mexican yeah did you get like
some
goat's head no super cause i always
wanted to eat like
mexican food in mexico not what we were
in cabo so we weren't lucky lately
i thought you went to tulum yeah but i
still got like tacos yeah we didn't go
to like a restaurant where there's
[ __ ] like fried maggots or something
you know right
i want to see something like that
mexican mexican some of the real [ __ ]
okay not the fake [ __ ]
i got tacos that's not real like those
food adventure shows
so it's the one restaurant that has
goats heads and fried yeah but i'll say
everyone eats that but
he wants the stuff that mexicans are
like we don't eat that yeah what the
[ __ ] everyone like the balloon
the rotten corn what i'm talking about
that has like
yeah like oh i heard of the rotten corn
i heard that [ __ ] the burton rotten corn
or like fried maggots or like
buried goat's head this guy's going
anywhere in asia can i get some dog
this one starts vlogging i'm at the
yulin dog festival
and i'm the real [ __ ] the real chinese
[ __ ]
we're at the one wet market are you
gonna eat this fake rice this is fake
nobody eats rice here who the [ __ ] wants
rice that's some stupid mainstream white
wine [ __ ]
we're gonna eat dog phoebe orange
chicken white rather that's whole
we even in america i was reading books
we ate crazy [ __ ] too like
all the frontier dudes they ate beaver
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] like weird [ __ ] like we don't you
know why we have possums right
california possums aren't we
possum yeah like when they were doing
the whole [ __ ] organ trail [ __ ] right
like when they're
coming over here they would have possums
because they're easy to catch
and they keep them in cages and they get
loose and stuff right and then that's
how
opossums came to california is because
people coming out west
you know that was their source of food
yeah because we ate raccoons we
all that we as a man not we america's
rich original americans we're eating all
that crazy [ __ ] i'd eat it you eat
whatever moves yes
i don't know where we all just drew the
line like there's a deal at the end of
the day we're going to eat only cow
and cow towels and pigs and delicious
stuff dude
probably a reason why they're easy to
raise probably to farm if they don't run
away far
or or they eat chicken chicken don't
even fly we don't eat smart things
that's for damn sure i mean other than
pigs pigs are pretty smart
imagine trying to keep a raccoon around
they'll [ __ ] you
up dude there's not a lot of meat though
it's not a lot of benefit yeah
you don't rabbit we rabbit we eat rabbit
you can still get rabbit and they're
pretty cute we don't get nuggets out of
a rabbit
but you're probably like after after
like generations genetically modified
like the raccoon that we end up eating
so they're just like super
sad wagyu raccoon
ragu yeah marbled raccoon mm-hmm
what's the difference between regular
beef and wagyu beef why is it wagyu so
wagyu is like well um
the it's like a different i guess breed
of cow but it's how
they make it because uh they
this cow lives better than all of us
first of all they say the problem with
regular cows are you know you're driving
up to five you see that the holocaust of
cows that they're like
the holocaust the holocaust they all
know they're gonna die
yep they're all scared the whole time
they go they're in a line to get killed
and they got those they're excreting
those hormones when we eat there we're
eating their fear
but real but real wagyu they think
they're
royalty they are because they drink
alcohol every day
they get like the good [ __ ] dude they
give them like hearing massages the
people massage them they massage them
yes yes and then so when you get trying
to get reincarnated
that's why it's so delicious though and
they don't move
like they just chill every [ __ ] day
someone jacks them off no i'm just
kidding
it's the it's the female so yeah yeah
because then you get the jackpot
they don't know they're going to die so
there's no there's no adrenaline or fear
in their meat they go out like that they
go like they like
whereas the other cows are watching
[ __ ] saw before they die
the other cows are on the [ __ ]
full-on
they don't get like they're just like in
their cage watching their friend die and
then you see
just like the number like slowly get to
them
they're like walking in line like oh
[ __ ] there's red right there because
they got that gun
that doesn't shoot yeah it just shoots
out like this far
boom and it goes right into their brain
and it just shuts them out boom they
just fall you're like
oh [ __ ] fresh down that's stress that's
up next oh god mass death
look at the meat though there's actually
like barely any muscle
it's all fat so when you get like a rib
eye steak that's wagyu
yeah it looks like a piece of like this
like white marble
yeah and that's why it's hella expensive
no fear in there
there's no fear just a lot of beer no
fear just beer
i guess the japanese thing is like we're
eating the fear of the animal
it's mainly the beer it's all fat dude
i don't think i've had the real [ __ ] i
think about it just heated up from
costco
yeah so i gotta try costco's real [ __ ]
you know no i know but there's like all
this
wagyu and you're like he took that
personally he was like yo costco
american wagyu is like um it's like a
crossbreed from the japanese wagyu like
cow with
angus or something like that are they
getting massaged and beard and
everything
that's why it's different like they
might just be free-range grass-fed like
a normal
like the way that cows are here it's
like one beer every now and then
they get do they got the fear in the in
the muscle i don't know where's the
wagon you guys have like a bar
it's like dude literally google it and
you'll see videos
of these [ __ ] getting massaged
and drinking [ __ ] beer
yeah they get ropes that they rub that
they throw over them and they [ __ ]
massage them and you see the cowgirl
like this
yeah they have a huge rope and then they
wrap it around the cow and then they
kind of do this thing
and then have this big bottle of kirin
like this huge
and then that food's drinking it like a
baby like it's like
i'm trying to get a drunk cow yeah every
day they get drunk
the cows are like man i got it made
there's no alternative reasons why
they're doing this for me it's just life
is good
the world is kind yeah they're just like
if i'm gonna go out
anyway [ __ ] it i just wanna know the
first the japanese dude that thought of
this i'm gonna get this [ __ ] drunk
every day what i wanna do we're gonna
[ __ ] up this cow anyway but like
let's just treat this cow as good as
possible
and then let's see we taste that that
[ __ ] was unintentional i bet you it was
like just some [ __ ] in the like ito era
or something like that
where like some dude you know how people
just like live like their animals
you know what i mean he probably just
had a cow best friend the same [ __ ] that
he did every day the cow just did it
every day if he got a cow got it if he
drank it the couch what childhood did
you have he had a cow best friend but
then but in the war went but
eat his friend he had to eat his friend
and he was the best cow he ever ate
his best friend was a cowgirl sometimes
i think like if we were all together we
just had to go
you know we're just living in the field
crazy but we like in the wilderness yeah
but we saw the cow like
us okay six of us be like how are we
gonna kill the cow
oh easy girl's gonna do it but we don't
got no weapons we ain't got no weapons
i'd get a big rock
you're gonna smash the [ __ ] out of it
yeah i'm hungry you know how many times
you gotta hit it though yeah and then
how we go like how are we gonna like
i mean how long is that cow gonna last
us a like we got do we have clothes on
yeah we're just know how many tools do
we have we don't have any tools we're
not gonna get them do we
are we in the rules here we've got capes
there's gotta be like a loan season
eight you know what i'm talking about
everybody watch that show so good like
make it in a lot we got we're like
naked he's afraid if i could survive for
like maybe two
three days without food and get rescued
i'd be fine i won't kill the cow but
we're not gonna be there for a year
oh yeah oh dude that
yeah but that cow is probably gonna go
bad if we don't know how to
preserve that [ __ ] how hungry was i when
i got off the plane to get there
yeah did i just have like two big macs
we'll probably have to smoke it all into
jerky that's true
that's delicious i asked a guy who owned
like some farmers
how was the best way for me to kill the
cow if i had to what do you say he said
get a paper
a plastic trash bag he's like you ain't
gonna be able to kill that cow
that's what got horns though i see that
you wouldn't even kill that cat with
a with a knife joe has to hide what he's
like eat the best because his leather
right yeah
yeah is to get a trash bag and put that
around the dude's head
just right where we gonna find a trash
bag in the forest maybe we could just
fill his mouth up we could choke him
with like grass or something have a big
rock to kill him but we had a trash bag
to suffocate his ass
keep putting trash bags in the forest
because it's actually helpful
thank you yeah don't know that why would
a cow be in the forest
they don't go they're never in the
forest
and we're naked we're naked we have no
tools
this just sounds like a porno all of a
sudden there's a [ __ ] cow
if i see a cow i know there's a owner
somewhere six guys one cow
and i'm gonna be like there's a there's
a hillbilly with a shotgun close by
that's gonna be like don't rape my cow
what's up everybody today's video is
brought to you by
hbo max so i know a lot of people
especially this day and age we're
looking for what's the newest show to
watch what's the newest movie to watch
something's really cool is happening
with hbo max where they're gonna have
the same
day movie premiere with warner brothers
movies on
hbo max that means when it comes out in
the theater
it's coming out in a living room which
is some people
have a great home theater yeah that's
even better than a movie theater
or sometimes you're you really want to
watch a movie and you're like oh man i
was gonna be so packed
but i just want my friends to come over
and watch a movie and guess what
now you can and i'm super excited
because like you know there's two movies
that'll be coming out
on hbo max and loki i don't really want
to go to the theater for
yeah but it's the conjuring because i
like scary scary
i love the whole series and space jam
because
i grew up on space jam so we saw jordan
now we're gonna see lebron james
so make sure to sign up for hbo max go
to hbom.ax
slash otr june to start streaming today
and remember you can stream warner
brothers movies the same
day it comes out you don't even have to
go to the movie theater
you can watch it on the app on your
phone in your bedroom in the living room
go check it out
and it's at no additional cost for the
subscribers
true check it out bye i would spend
probably like the first
day just making weapons though yeah yeah
like sharpening rocks or making
[ __ ] how did we get there did we
crash a plane in our clothes bird
like fortnight life real life fortnight
wait what
i need you to pick this picture for me
like did we crash on the plane
and then we burned did all of our
clothes just yeah here's the picture
right look at this right now
i know lawn claws and clothes loan
cloths and clothes
i need you to pay this picture okay
naked
and that's it and are there an easier
animal was there like a fish
yeah i guess like why are we killing
those hard ass animals there's easier
animals laying around
i'm just saying that we eat so many cows
but they're hard to kill
forget it we gotta kill other animals
until we figure out what to do i'll eat
a [ __ ] bug or something first
you need a snack protein you need
protein i think i think we should be
practical though we should befriend the
cow so we gain its trust over a period
of time because we might at work
a week like three we might be like let's
[ __ ] kill this cow
dude no way once we name the cow i'm not
gonna want to kill the cow i'll be a
[ __ ] vegan
crazy even like a number you know what i
mean okay that's better like
serial number like what if it's cereal
you'd kill
chicken though you just kill the chick
and eat it regardless with that
with the trash bag though it has to be
with the trash but let me let me ask you
guys this right
we're going to be there for a year right
right we could get milk
we can get this cow to plow our [ __ ]
farm can you get milk you can get eggs
i know but the cow has to get
impregnated and have a baby to get milk
don't tell he's going to make us butter
somebody come in the cow joe has to do
it bro but plow in a field as possible
what if it was a bowl don't we need to
make oh
[ __ ] we got no milk we ain't got no
tools but we're gonna make a plow we
just gotta jack them off and drink that
this is how we kill the cow bro we put
the cow below a tree we get real high on
the tree and we just drop
rocks and this one just decides to go oh
is it is that does that work
and then you drop it and then the cow
walks
this way oh what's that yeah and then
douche
hey he trying to kill me man he wouldn't
even know he wouldn't even know this is
all we have to do is we have to find a
cliff
like what the natives did and just push
it off the cliff look bro anthony didn't
like that one bro he was like what
that's actually not a bad idea but
that's what they did that's how they
hunted back in the
great american place but now you gotta
go all the way down the [ __ ] cliff
was it wasn't there a thing called cow
tipping yeah yeah
didn't that eventually kill them they
don't kill them though that's just
because they sleep on their feet so if
you push them over
if it was like that then all factory
farms would just be oh take the cow into
the ocean and drown his ass
you think just teenagers went out in the
middle of night and just killed cows my
teeth remember like that's [ __ ] up
that's [ __ ] dark dude
interesting [ __ ] up things man do you
think anyone's ever been caught
[ __ ] a cow oh probably but then
they're like oh it's a science
experiment
no you can't [ __ ] you can't [ __ ] a
cat why well you're not tall enough
you're not hey on top people are putting
their whole arms in cows oh
[ __ ] that's why we can [ __ ] them right
hey let's go
you can't put your dick in no cap wait
you get get up on a stool or something
right yeah but i mean
they put their arm in the butthole to
help right to take the
conservation of it oh yeah that's to
take the [ __ ] out right yeah they got
those long ass gloves and [ __ ]
it's always brown this is a cultural
thing for my people by the way so i'd
appreciate it if you guys didn't comment
on it because
[ __ ] cows is kind of what we do
you can't [ __ ] it's a cow like i
think a sheep
you can bro no offense but yeah you're
just not you're it's not your
you never seen people [ __ ] donkeys huh
look how big steve is
you could take it on a couch easy
you're thinking from asian size we're
shorter oh so asian cow
you can play a wacky cow get them drunk
first would you rather [ __ ] sheep
ask the hard-hitting questions
definitely definitely definitely sheep
people actually do definitely sheep but
i like petite girl oh my god
okay if you want my honest answer sheep
yeah it has to be a shoe she could like
the hair it's like soft
so why would you why would you have to
who would put you in this
like are you like like are you in a
psychopath like a
we're in a psychopath farm right it's
like that it's like the [ __ ] science
of the labs right guarantee
somewhere in the world someone's [ __ ]
[ __ ] right now lamb is not gonna be
silent oh dude
there's a documentary right now about a
[ __ ] whole village that [ __ ] donkeys
it's
it's a documentary no in this culture
right
they believe in order to become a man
you have to first
[ __ ] a donkey for practice but some guys
they get so
used to [ __ ] donkeys that they don't
want women anymore you know what
that's totally fine with me you have an
insult
how long is that culture gonna last who
doesn't understand women at all he's
like
yo guys like you guys got to [ __ ] this
sheep i'm the authority here
yeah that's that's how you become a man
you guys don't have sex with girls until
you [ __ ] this [ __ ] they say you gotta
practice on a donkey why don't you don't
you can't even good luck people are you
that's why they're cold jackasses
donkeys ain't even good looking get
yourself a nice sheet
that's right that's where it's curly
hair
wake up yeah you can rub your fingers
through the hair oh my god
grab that hair i don't know about you
guys but i'm more like a dog
aquatic dolphin mammal like that's
that's a slippery slip slipper slide
slip and slide slipping
talking about like a beluga whale huh
yeah they are fine
they got they curvy dude there is a
netflix movie about a guy having a
relationship with
a dolphin there is dude guys we'll [ __ ]
anything what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
wait no he went to um
i forget the name of the show but the
dude went to uh
to like an aquatic show like sea world
whatever in florida
and he said it was love at first sight
and then he ended up getting a job at
the place
so he could like he got a job to [ __ ]
this dolphin like
him and the dolphins saw each other and
they it was like love at first sight
the glass never like put their hands up
mutual
mutual i hope that never happens to me i
need i need to find a movie like that
it's on netflix it's like a real i want
that to be a love story it is a love
story what's the movie called
it's available how do you subscribe to
netflix i think it's on netflix and i
listen to podcasts too i was like this
is the craziest story i ever heard
but then he wasn't the only in the
doctor are we judgmental for not
understanding him though
i think so yeah yeah bro why are you
falling over the dolphin yo they
and they they said they had sex he said
like we have sex
how dude i think dolphins have dicks hey
is he
homosexual no but i think he had a
female he was having sex with a female
dolphin and a girl was having sex with a
melanoma
does he have to have sex with a snorkel
on their mammals i mean what do you do
[ __ ] the blowhole
i don't know i was just watching like
this is crazy
at the [ __ ] park at the [ __ ] world
it was one of the shows
he got he ended up getting a job there
he fell in love with her
went to a bunch of shows and [ __ ]
slipped in at night in the pool [ __ ]
you got a job at the park and then bro
how crazy is that this guy
got a job at sea world to [ __ ] dolphins
not sea world but it was from
florida florida to rome oh my bad to
romance and [ __ ]
it was love at first sight but did they
say that he [ __ ] the dog but she
didn't consent fool
yeah no she was in there too i don't
think they were both yeah she said she's
like
dolphins supposedly are very high forms
of uh
they are very intelligent beings and you
know apparently very romantic i think if
you have a season pass to sea world you
should be investigated
because i don't know why you'd want to
go back i don't know why i didn't want
to go one time that's what i'm saying
bro if you're [ __ ] dolphins bro you
gotta go to jail no yeah you guys
depends on this no what if this dolphin
wants it
you haven't seen the [ __ ] arctic
arctic penguin
show that's the best dude they dude okay
you go on this
elevator belt and it moves for your lazy
ass
and then you stand on it and you can
just watch all these guys playing this
like little kids and tuxedos and [ __ ]
swimming and playing with each other
it's pretty awesome i'd watch that i'd
watch that in new zealand i went to this
thing and you go
and then you sit in these stands and
wait when the sun sets like what the
[ __ ] are we doing here
and then all of a sudden like wait wait
and then all of a sudden
two penguins walk out the water oh damn
little penguins and then
thousands of penguins every night just
going home to their thing
and all the humans just like watching
the painting don't touch them
wait this is in nature this is in nature
this is real
what wow how long ago was this this is
like a few years are you on a conveyor
belt at all
no conveyor belt no nothing just stands
you just sit there you can't take no
pictures or nothing
can't take have sex with penguins they
said some japanese people trying to take
them home one time like they're
getting back on the bus they had three
penguins in there they're holding them
like maybe nobody will say you gotta put
that [ __ ] back they're just trying to go
home
this is just nature oh i don't speak
english
[Laughter]
the penguins consent but it was crazy to
see thousands of penguins walk out i
said every day they walk
they go home they're trying to make some
wagyu penguins dude get them drunk and
[ __ ]
they go back to the ocean and during the
day and they go do the what the hell
they gotta do that's that's the real
march of the penguin that's the real
march the penguin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you